so the recording show just initiated
thanks again everybody for attending
this is easy C and C with shop turns
setup from programming this content will
be specific to the eight twenty eight
and eight forty control going through
operation of the system jogging some
confusion offsets will look at some
content as we go through as well as part
programming
my name is Chris Pollak for those of you
that may not be familiar with me
I am the dealer support specialist for
the East Coast for Siemens and I will be
I will be presenting today's content for
you my information is up there on the
screen certainly if you don't have a
chance to write it down now and you
don't have it again these recordings
will be posted for the viewing signal
back to get my information if you'd like
to reach out to me with further
questions
so this these live seminars they're new
for us we've been trying to get them out
once a month over the last a few months
we've had a few that are ready already
gone through and we have a bunch more
coming up in the future so today we're
certainly doing the shop turn set up a
programming content next one's going to
be a little tight with the test shows so
I probably won't have an opportunity to
post the next one till October but the
next one will be shot milk so it'll be
very similar layout content but it'd be
specific to shop milk for the a 28 May
for tea after that we do a commonality
between shop milk program guide EDM and
ISO mode so that will kind of show you
how all the different modes of the
control kind of work together and I can
move between them depending on depending
on how you create your programs whether
they're coming out of camp system you're
writing a keyboard at the control or use
example so that'll be another one and
then we'll have many many more coming up
in the future the content will be
specific to you know any of the three
primary controls in our in our market
842 8:28 and the 808 control as well I
did say earlier but all of these
recordings are posted on our CNC free
website as well so you can access that
if you would like to so today again
we're specifically looking at the a 28
and the 840 platforms overview today
we're going to take a look at CNC shop
turn and apply it to a two axis turning
machine so we'll go in we'll talk about
set up a little bit talk about how to
set some basic part zeros moving machine
around great some tools we're certainly
going to go in and create a core program
and even go as far as run it in the
machine so you should get a pretty good
understanding from start to finish of
what it would take to set up a job
create a basic program and even run it
in this system
this is the example we're going to use
when we get to our programming example
so a simple turning example we're going
to face off our part we're going to
create a contour as you see we'll put a
nice little relief we're going to come
down in and machine a thread on the part
we'll machine a one inch eight thread on
this part once we've done that we're
going to drill a hole through the center
of the part so you get a chance to see
how the drilling cycles work and then
we're going to Park the part off using
recordable cycle so when we're all said
and done we should have any complete
part I will keep bouncing back to a PDF
that I have just to refer you back to
the dimensional data as we start to put
different features in this this webinar
is probably going to take anywhere from
an hour to an hour and a half I didn't
want to cut it short so we'll get right
into it right now so the first section
we're going to look at it's going to be
job mode so in jog mode we're first
going to take a look at the jog screen
or the manual screen so this would be my
main screen where I can start to move
the Machine around we can do tool
changes we can set some basic offsets so
we'll come through we'll talk about the
TSM screen then we're going to go and
look at how to set a tool zero and a
part zero through the measure workpiece
or the measure tool function we'll take
a look at the offset table a little bit
right create a tool and we could even
maybe create a tool as we're writing the
program I do have electric tools pre
created for us as well so with that
being said what we're going to do is
we're going to switch over to our sinew
Train software and sinew train is
basically a machine tool emulator so it
is the identical software you would see
running physically on your control it
gives you all the same functionality so
I can move the machines around I can set
0 going to auto mode on one part program
so it gives us a very good
representation of what the machine tool
would do in an offline piece of software
and this software is absolutely
available in the marketplace so if you'd
like to purchase it is very available
for you so the first screen of first
function we were going to talk about is
the TS
field so first before we going further
where am I added and control what am I
looking at well right now we're in the
jog screen I know I'm in the jog screen
because if I look in the upper left hand
corner I see I'm in my mission my
machine mode and my jog screen light is
up typically this is usually the first
screen you see whenever you power
pollution for possibly if your machine
requires referencing you may see the
reference point screen first to initiate
a cycle start or go through whatever the
manufacturer-specific homing process
would be and then if that's the case the
next screen you will see be jog
generally it's one of those first
screens you always see in the PowerPoint
machine so the jog screen was created to
allow you to start moving around the
machine setting all sense now we created
the functionality of this screen to be
very aware of keeping things simple for
operators not bombarding them with a lot
of heavy cumbersome commands and
instructions so you'll notice as we go
through it there's a very a lot of
visually graphical screens that can
guide you through the process of setup
and moving machine around we keep you
from having to go to maybe like MDI
screens and put in a lot of G or an
import from ssin ality just to keep
things simple so with that being said
the first screen we're going to take a
look at is our TSM screen and that is
the button in the lower left-hand corner
of my display and what TSM allows me to
do is TSM allows me to do tool changes
spindle commands other M codes so if I
want to fire my coolant or something
along the line in the mist or whatever I
happen to have attached it to the
machine I can load different work
officer I can even chain my unit of
measure so all this stuff is very
typical functionality that you would
always do through an MDI screen and a
control but by creating this simple
little interface screen it keeps the
users from having to know and learn all
these heavy-handed commands so if I want
to do something as simple as just
physically change my tool now if I look
at the tsf window the tsf window is just
a quick representation what's active at
this point in the control so it knows
that I have some punch cutter physically
loaded
maybe some fees or some spindle speed
states so if I simply come down and I
can move my highlight around my blue
arrow to my tool field I can now hit the
Select tool key in the upper right hand
corner and get access to my tool table
so my tool table is showing me all the
different tools that are physically
loaded in the machine horrible so let's
say we wanted to spin tutor position
number one and bit to our CNN G 432 or
our 80 degree OD rapping tool all I can
simply highlight that tool by moving up
with the blue arrow keys select okay
machine fills out the name of my tool
and now it's just waiting for simple
cycle start by pressing cycle start will
initiate a tool change automatically
important so the machine now would do
anything the Builder prompted or wanted
it to do for talking to it has to go to
a retrack location and go to that
retrack location if they're just
allowing the third to spin at that point
it would do that but you'll notice in
the TFS screen I now see my new tool
loaded in my turn so it's fun to that
position would have loaded any offsets
that may be set that tool and I can now
continue moving on that tool I'll use
this for maybe turning my spindle on so
let's say for argument's sake I want to
start up my main spindle at 500 rpm and
I want to give it a direction I'm going
to use my select key to define some kind
of a direction so maybe I want to go
clockwise and now I'm going to simply
hit the cycle start key and you'll see I
spin a little turn on my feedback will
even show me that the spindle is now
spinning everything is running so these
are the typical steps I would use to
spin the turret to some location fire my
spindle and get ready for maybe setting
a tool setting an offset as well if I
wanted to load up a work coordinate I
could come in select a specific work
coordinate that I want to use that I'm
going to activate from setting zeros
cycle start and that would initiate
loading of that work or anything within
the GSM screen will require a physical
cycle start to then activate I can also
use this to
maybe terminal back off if I wanted to
but using the X with the circle through
it it's like I'm starting that command
spindle tool so you'll use the TSM
screen to do a lot of your standard
manual functions from there let's say I
wanted to jog the machine around so I
can jog utilizing my axes right here so
I take a given axis I can select the
plus or minus key I can start to move
the machine around maybe I want to move
Z so I select thee you'll notice this
has a y-axis plus about other axes
certainly this machine could support
many axes this one's just commissioned
for a couple this was built to support C
axis capability and light rolling we
won't be going through that today but we
could in the future absolutely so with
that being said maybe I want to come in
and set a tool on set very common
occurrence that you'll find yourself
doing when setting up a job for a lathe
well certainly the first step would be
load the actual tool that I want to set
you know potentially turn my spindle on
to some direction because I'm going to
come in and pick a little light Pat or
whatnot and then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use this measure tool
function so measure tool allows us to
come in and set our tool offsets so once
I select the measure tool button is
selected by going blue I just clicked on
that button I can now pick in the upper
vertical soft keys are operating in
corner the manual or the automatic
buttons so manual would be I'm not going
to physically come in and manually set
this tool probably take a light cut on a
piece of material automatic would be if
I had a preset or let's a machine so
we're going to go through just manually
setting the tool today I select the
manual function you'll see that the tool
is already pre-selected it knows what's
in the third or what's loaded so it
automatically defines that I would then
probably you know jog machine or angular
machine to some location come in take a
light cut we would go down measure up
our part maybe my cup that diameter and
then I would tell the system in the x0
field what is the diameter I'm
physically sitting at so you know you
usually take a cot mover straight back
and Z leaving the X is still aligned
with that edge shut the spindle off
measure it maybe we found that we were
to and a half inches I simply type the
diametric value to point five this is
will automatically cut that in half for
you and then I merely type it in and
then press the SEC length function so
before I hit it I want you to take a
look at our work field the work field is
displaying our absolute positions
relative to some offset from zero so you
see how it's sitting at twenty three
point six eight right now we hit set
length and all of a sudden it applies to
two point five in our control whenever
you set any offsets we will immediately
load those offsets
same scenario if I was to adjust the
offset maybe by flying aware so we were
running this tool we wanted to maybe go
to the offset table go to my where field
and tell it that I'm maybe I was a
little big so I want to reduce the
offset by five bow well if I come back
out you notice I didn't physically do
anything with the tool or move the
machine but immediately it's reflecting
that also so whenever you're setting any
offsets you always want to verify in all
that's the tool that's called up or the
work cornets hold up that the display
physically change if it didn't you need
to stop and kind of go back and figure
out maybe what you did wrong as to why
that tool didn't properly update or that
it also didn't update so in this case Z
if it came over to the light cut in the
face of the part I could tell it zero I
can tell it some small positive would
make a distance depending on where I'm
setting it but I did the same process I
give it a value
I hit set length my offsets change
now you're going to do a lot with
measure tool because you have a lot of
tools to set up typically in the lathe
so here I can stay within this screen so
let's say I was to move back move out a
little bit now I want to change to some
other tool well if you have arrow back
up to the T field in the measure tool
field we can initiate tool changes just
like the TSM you just saw so here I hit
select tool we can maybe arrow down to
our finish cutter say okay that tool
name is now loaded we'll talk about tool
names in a little bit okay some tools
but the tool is physically loaded now I
just have to execute it by hitting a
cycle start you see now loads the new
tools my offsets change because I don't
have an offset yet for them now I would
repeat the same process
I would potentially jog down jog over
some location maybe will Z and then give
the Machine tilt whatever axis I'm
setting it will retain the value so if
I'm just going to touch a lot on to a
predefined axis value I don't have to
keep typing them each time then I just
say set length for each of them and I've
just established y'all set so just
follow that pulses the graphics will
update depending on the tool that you
selected so you know if you go to drill
and then mills you'll see it'll update
to reflect that and try to give you a
little better process of what we'd be
expecting you would do to set this tool
generally there's a lot of different
ways to set up blades
generally you know a lot of guys like
the setup alder tool offsets either to a
fixed datum or to maybe just the part
and then they'll adjust all the tools by
applying some value in a record so in
our machine you can do that by simply
going in I'm just going to put that
turning to Adam before back in we're
simply going to my measure workpiece
field measure workpiece allows me to
move over to some location so maybe I
was to move to some position
this is let's say where I wanted to set
a work coordinate value so what the work
order value would do a little move all
this will the same amount so if I had
pre-established maybe all of my tools to
the base of my chocolate set and I want
it to now move over just one given tool
touch the front of my new part and then
have all the tools set there this would
be a good example of where I would use I
measure workpiece field I would move the
machine back touch a physical part
select whichever work coordinate I want
to work I want to use tell it what I
want this value to be so maybe I'm
hitting a 1 2 3 block use a paper shim
stock I could tell it may be a small
value from there hit set work coordinate
you see ma my display changes now that
value didn't change for the tool offset
it actually applied to the work
coordinate so we'll go into look at the
offset table in here in a second and
you'll see where some of these values
grow as well other common things you can
do within the job screen will be maybe
position the Machine around so here I
can tell to you know feed the Sun
location maybe I wanted to go to an X or
2 inches cycle start machine would run
and do that as commanded feed move and
do rapid moves here so you can just kind
of move the Machine around its work
envelope this way we give you a basic
stock removal screen this is a simple
can cycle that allows you to do a simple
stock removal so if you wanted to turn
some soft jobs like today and maybe I'm
going to work on an ID set of soft rolls
I wouldn't have to write a whole program
I could fill out this one little event
once I fill it out and I have good
numbers here then you will get the
accept key and once it's happy this
becomes a little program so like that
will go and hit cycle start and this
program should run I didn't give it any
valid numbers but it's a just quick snip
away from able to do some basic like
that and depending on the machine tool
you purchased and how the Builder is
configured it we may bring up a lot of
these different hand cycles up on the
screen a lot of our teach lathes engine
lanes that have the ability
running on a manual on CNC like a hybrid
machine they'll give you a whole bunch
of different camp cycles up in this mode
and they all work kind of the same way
now what we want to look at here as well
we were kind of moving the Machine
around and jogging around setting
pro-law sex I do want to show you the
offset screen briefly so in the offset
screen I'm going to get there by getting
my hard offset button I will see our
tool table and the tool table is a
physical tool list the tool list is
going to contain the tool the offsets
and some of the geometry that makes up
the given tool tool where is just how I
can adjust small incremental values
aware I also have my tool life
management here magazine is more
reserved for machines with like milling
machines with random tool changes and
Parham cells and whatnot but you do have
the ability of that functionality here
as well as a more complex machine then
offsets is where all of my work
coordinate or work off sensor cetera so
if I come in and I look at my g54 I can
see where that number got inserted when
I did that or coordinate offset set so
just like when I set my clever tool now
these values are a distance from some
machine location potentially to wherever
I was setting the tool if I was
basically everything off of this of a
gauge tool overworked coordinate then
these could potentially be just small
incremental values from some data to
that tip so with that being said let's
say I wanted to create a tool from
scratch why don't we build one at least
so you can see the mechanism certainly
we don't have enough time to build all
the tools for the whole part program but
if we can build one or two it'll give
you a pretty good understanding of at
least the start of the mechanism so the
way tools work in the Siemens world is
you're going to potentially have tools
sitting in a physical location this
would be a position or that is
physically loaded in the machine or they
can be in what we call an unloaded State
so we allow you to build or move tools
from inside of the machine tool through
outside locations just by being in a
loaded State meaning they have a
location to the lamp is
in the machine or we call an unloaded
state meaning that they still exist but
they don't exist in the machine some
builders force you to make tools that
are automatically in an unloaded state
and then go through loading process
other builders do not really clean it up
to the Builder how he wants to set up
the machine so in this case let's say
I'm going to build a tool in an unloaded
state I could select new tool and now I
see a full tool library of different
tools we support we're initially just
looking at what we call our favorites
screen so this is some very common tools
you might want to use then you can go
into more detail tool doing all
different kinds of cutters right angle
heads and all sorts of different die
mold and Mills and fall end mills drills
social reserve and drills and taps we
support all kinds of been turning tools
we do special probes and star probes and
stops the whole large list of cool
libraries that are here for you normally
most of stuff you're going to use can be
found under the favorite screen so let's
say for argument's sake we were going to
come in and create a standard standard
turning tool so maybe it's going to be a
roughing tool so I'm going to leave the
roughing tool highlighted and then I
have these orientations now maybe hard
to see on your end but if you look close
you'll notice that the first one has a
little orange tinge to it orange you
know in relation to the other tools well
I can move that orange highlight around
to each of the tools using my arrow keys
so this is how I define the orientation
of the tool how it sits in the physical
machine this machine is set up as it was
a slam bed so this is a rear turret so
this first tool would represent an OD
tool if this machine was a front turret
machine then you would see everything
would get looked backwards our icons our
placement will always represent or match
the way the machine is built so the
first position always represents ability
tool but you might see the icon would
look like this third one over here so
what you'll do is you'll kind of scroll
through and you have a whole bunch of
I'm going to do neutral tools and get
all my orientations for my neutral
tools we have in this case eight
different orientations I can pick from
so this one I'm going to pick my first
orientation and I'm going to say okay
now I happen to have the naming
automatically turned on so it gave me a
rough name and this is probably one of
the first things that guys notice that's
a major difference from us to a lot of
our competitors is the fact that tools
do not have to be numbers normal they
can be there's nothing wrong with being
a number but you can call it anything
you want I like it because I can build
in kind of user comments or notes right
into the name of the tool so let's say
for argument's sake I wanted to build a
35 degree tool I could tell it it's a
mic capsule on a VN mg and maybe it was
a 3/32 insert IC and radius and I happen
to know that that is an OD tool so this
would be a normal way for me to put in
some different information I have right
in the name of tool chipbreaker you get
pretty elaborately we support quite a
few quite a few characters within a
given name you type in the name whatever
you want letters numbers we support
anything you want there even you see
forward slashes and so on line we can do
special characters you hit enter and
then it moves the highlight over to the
X life enter on the control would also
be the yellow input button right here
the length for X and the length for Z
will get filled out when you do the set
length functionality so you don't have
plain numbers in there unless you happen
to know your presetting tools or have
known data but you can tag them
indirectly the next thing would be my
radius I have a number two rad so that
would be no 31 radius so I'm going to
type it my primary cutting direction now
the system figured that out based on the
orientation I chose but if I wanted to
flip things around I could change my
primary cutting direction certainly the
two primaries for this tool would either
be down or to the left you'll notice if
I put the wrong cutting direction we put
a little indicator here on the insert
the same things aren't quite driving
so in this case I'm telling it to have a
left handed tool but cut to the right
which doesn't like that very much
so we'll do a standard left hand tool
color direction the next field is our
relief angle and that is basically my
clearance we look at this insert picture
to top the screen it's the angular
distance so it's always added from 90
degrees so if I have a 5 degree relief
I'm going to put 95 in but I have a 3
degree relief 93 7 is 97 so you're just
going to take 90 degrees and then add
whatever that relief angle is 2 we have
the insert physical little insert angle
I know this to be a 35 degrees since the
nmg and then I have the IC of the
inserts we'll save it and I see the IC
is that
inscribed circle in the insert right so
that's how we can kind of understand how
big the insert is from there there's a
couple extra fields you have your
standard cut direction for this tool so
if I was inverting the tool or something
like that I can flip it over and then I
have my physical coolants and you may or
may not see multiple coolants really
kind of depends on if the machine was
built with a couple different cones so a
lot of times I'll just see one that
would be a standard for one then maybe
the second to high pressure or washdown
or something along those long so once
that's all filled out I'm all set my
tool is created and defined I have all
the information I need to know now in
this case the tool is unloaded so we
know it exists but it's not physically
in the machine so let's say it's time to
mount the tool and remove scene you want
to put it in the machine
I'm simply going to make sure this tool
is highlighted anywhere on this little
matter and then I'm going to use the
load button on my vertical softkeys load
allows me to say hey I'm good look for
the machine right and where do I want to
put it so maybe I knew that I want to
put it in pocket 16 I type it in say ok
it's physically moved up do I now I have
to actually mount the pool in the turret
absolutely this is just a mechanism for
us to manage the pools but what's nice
is if you guys are dealing with a lot of
tools you're breaking down setups all
the time you know I can come in and say
hey I'm not using the creative demo
right now but the tool is still a valid
tool potentially going to put it back in
the machine at some point so I can just
highlight the tool select unload and
you'll see they didn't delete the toilet
and lose its data just sitting in an
unloaded state how many tools can I
support in this screen it's really up to
the Builder it is builder selectable but
most the time I see most builders will
support 99 tools
so it's however many locations we have
here and then the rest of it till it
equals i9 but we can support thousands
of tools so it's really really up to a
function of the builder now the other
thing I do want to point out when taking
a look at tools in our system is what we
call multiple cutting edges so in the
Siemens world you can actually create up
to nine unique offsets for any given
tool typically when using this
functionality in maybe some competitive
controls you would have had to sacrifice
another offset number to use to be able
to do this type of functionality so you
know maybe I had 99 offsets I would have
to say okay well I'll use offset 20 to
match with one tool one when I want to
use a have a dummy offset or have a
different offset in our world you simply
select the edges function and edges will
allow you to create a whole new offset
so all I do is I select new cutting edge
and now you see how I get a second one
now there's no number this doesn't mean
it's not loaded this just means that
these two are associated in the Siemens
world when you're dealing with multiple
cutting edges you will then get a new
number under your D field and this is
how it gets cold up in the park problem
it's a D number from t1 through d9 so
you'll never see a D number larger than
because that's the maximum number
offsets we support and then from there
there shows match this number so this
can be a completely completely unique
tool doesn't even have to be the same
physical tool you know if I had a little
gang tool set up here and I knew that
that I had a turning tool a threading
tool and a portable on a little game
setup I could do that right now I could
come in and say okay well my second
cutting edge is going to be going to be
a threading tool or my second cutting
edge is going to be a part off tool now
the one thing it doesn't let me change
is the name because it's always linked
to this turret position so if only one
name so you might want to call it
Universal or something like that but now
these offsets are completely unique so
there's there's no Association in this
case now well I will see with instead of
the angle this is my insert with so if
this was a 100 dollar wide grooving tool
I would just tell you point one here or
it will excuse me
I would type point one for my grooving
tool width and that would be some of the
parameters you just regrouping tool okay
so we are now going to jump back over to
our power point here for a second and
we're going to take a look at the next
area we're going to explore in this this
seminar so for next thing we want to
talk about is our program manager so you
can start to see some of the functions
you can start to use to set up a job Jud
jog the Machine around and create some
tools the program manager is an area for
you to manage the programs in the
machine you're going to get to the
program manager area by selecting the
program manager button that's typically
a hard key somewhere on your panel all
of the hard keys can also be accessed
via soft keys by simply being the menu
select key so if you have some kind of a
custom front panel or whatnot which is
very common in our control you may want
to just find the menu select key once
you hit menu select you will see those
soft keys come up we'll look at that in
a second we met for the live portion of
the demo
within program manager I'll get a list
of directories and areas where I can
start state programs so you take a look
at that I have the ability of creating
directories creating different types of
programs so you're going to get a chance
to see how to how to physically start
and initiate a shop term program
we can save setup data so all those
fields are features you saw within the
tool table can be saved as a physical
file so not only can you manage you know
part program specific to a job but also
the tool data that makes up and the full
data is all the tools as well as all the
offsets all of your workbook sets as
well it can be saved so we can take a
peek at that and then from there once
we've created it a part program we're
going to go in in this shop turn
programming interface and we're going to
start to take a look at all of the
different kind of elements that make up
a shop term program so the first thing
we'll see is the program header that's
always going to be that first initial
screen we always see or start a program
and there's a bunch of basic parameters
we'll fill out in there and explain to
what they do then we're going to get to
the event editor and this is where we
actually start to give the program some
depth you know this is where we start to
tell the Machine what it's going to do
so we're going to first come into the
editor and it will basically be blank
and then we'll start picking the
operations using our software buttons
like drilling or turning to go to a
defined location or operation we'll get
a chance to see some of the canned
cycles in this job we're going to use a
basic turning cycle for facing and then
we're going to go into our contour
editor to machine in a regular shape
where then once we've programmed up the
part going to get a chance to take a
look at it in our 2d and 3d simulation
mode and we can start to look at cutter
paths and different features on the part
maybe look at the three dimensions maybe
cut it to start to look at some of the
internals
especially when you get to some
intricate internal work it's a nice way
to be able to see what's going on inside
of the part and that gives us now an
opportunity to go in and physically
explore some of these features so I'm
going to select CMU train again it's
going to put us back over to the Senya
train portion of the looks into this
demo from here like I said I'm going to
use the program manager to get the
program manager this button will get me
right there but if you can't find the
button for some reason to simply find
wherever the menu
Kia's many select is always somewhere on
on a front art panel that's a must as
far as all buttons there's usually two
you always see menu select and machine
menu select and then I could see the
different soft buttons for so program
manager here there's the software button
for program manager sometimes we change
our names on a physical function at the
end of the day as one of the icon
matches so if you look at the parameters
button here the second one over and you
look at the offset button the hard
button called offset then you see that
the same icon goes this in place we just
happen to use a different name and the
software button that we do in the heart
button that's all same thing with
Diagnostics or alarm same place if you
alarm button it's going to go to the
alarm area
if I hit menu select the diagnosis
button goes to the same area the alarm
so again you can hit program manager to
get there or you can hit menu select and
then program monitor you come in and
this is the program manager so this is
where all of our programs reside and the
control what your first seeing is the NC
directory so this is the active internal
NC memory in the machine with Denny NC
memory we've kind of set it up to feel
very similar to like a Windows
environment so I make first come up and
see my three core folders our program
sub programs and work pieces I can use
my blue arrow to move my cursor up or
down I can use my right or my left arrow
to expand or compress different folders
I'm going to look at so here is areas
where I can start to find where my part
programs resign now programs in the end
in the part program folder can only have
and must have an MPF extension that's a
stands for main program file so you
can't have any additional different
types of programs here this is just a
simple folder we start creating Park
programs if you want to start to create
your own sub programs and group
different programs I have all kinds of
different files and whatever at the
machine PDFs you can have the prints is
that
if you wanted to all that needs to be
done in the workpiece folder so in
workpiece I have the ability of
selecting new and creating a directory
so by selecting directory I could say
this is going to be my demo programs
whatever
now when creating folders I can use
letters I can use numbers the same thing
with file names but other than that the
only extra character we support in a
name especially in a file name is an
underscore in fact if you try to do a
space or minus sign - drinks will pay
that we don't support that character so
when creating names it's either a letter
a number or an underscore this case I'm
creating a directory so now you'll see
it created this demo programs directory
if I expand it there's nothing in it yet
but now I can start bringing programs in
around you know a question that always
comes up in this area is how do I move
programs in a row well you have a bunch
of different ways to programs wrong or
areas where the programs can be residing
shall I say one simple way to move
around and that's places like our USB
maybe a CF card maybe I could have a
mapped drive on a network and it will
show up like a button like my local
Drive button new so wherever I want to
go I'm just going to select the device
level to USB and plug in USB into
machine USB button would bill black out
and hit it and then would show me
potentially whatever sitting on that USB
my local Drive happens to be a mapped
Drive I have on the machine so you know
in this case maybe I wanted to come and
you know go and grab a specific file
like I got some example here's a sub
program so you find wherever the
whatever the file is you want to bring
over and it's now it's simply as simple
as using my cut copy paste commands on
the vertebral soft keys so select copy
go over to wherever you want to place it
this case I'll place it in my demo parks
it
aced the files now as well
you can edit file sitting a remote spots
you can even run on football soil if you
wanted to run it on a file right from
the USB or from your local Drive we tend
to discourage people from running on the
US because it's not the most robust or
stable of connections inherently ending
with detection we've got a couple little
pressure pins but it can absolutely be
done as far as we're concerned you can
treat it as an external drive if you
want me to if I wanted to get rid of a
program I can expand my vertical softly
though we're waiting the double arrow
button and then I get the Delete key and
delete all warn me of course and then it
will delete that program from that
directory not from where the source was
I would have so they're going to in this
example we are going to create a new
part program so I'm just like new and
we're going to create a name so shop
turn whatever I want to call it off all
this simple one type in my name select
ok I want to make sure shop turn is
highlighted I'm in creating part program
so the first step in the part program is
to fill out the header page and that's
the page you're physically looking at
right now question 1 what's the unit of
measure am I using a work coordinate or
not describe you may or may not see
that's more common in machines
supporting sub spindles or live tools
and whatnot gives us the ability of
actually writing for the work
coordinates from our program generally
I'll just leave this had no special
basics to access machine the blank
allows us to describe what the stock
looks like for simulation is it cylinder
is it a pipe is it some kind of square
saw is it some kind of hex stock so a
lot of different support of different
shapes of material then you define the
dimensions so in this case I'm saying
that my OD stocks two and a quarter I'm
going to leave a little bit of positive
material so I'm establishing myself all
of my tools or the face of my part to be
Z zero anything negative into my part is
going to be a negative number
anything in front of my part or clear my
part is going to be a positive
so I'm just saying hey I want to leave
25,000 material to get cleaned up with
my facing tool
what's the rough overall length of the
blank so this is always going to be
greater than Z B which is how far from
the Chuck jaws of collet face is the
part sticking out and this is important
because this is going to give me an
indication if I get too close to my work
holding and I potentially have a crash
condition retract how do I want to pull
off the part when you get into maybe
more complex work like IV work or back
turn work you can toggle and have a
bunch of different retracts if I'm just
doing a simple OD job which basically in
this case we are I'm just going to give
it a basic read tractor simple retract
the recheck values can either be
incremental or absolute I personally
like to use incremental if I can except
when I get into an ID boring application
then sometimes it's nice to give it the
you know the smallest diameter that that
one could for 2 in this case I'm just
leaving 100,000 e surface that I can
track although just be careful if you
set this to absolute or that's an
absolute location so this would then
have to become a value greater than the
part stock if I did less then I could be
getting errors or colliding into the
part from there what is very unique to
our control is the ability of defining
the tool change location in the part
program so this tool change point is
where the machine will physically go
tool changer this is also unique to just
turning the mills is different so in
this case I can define two options I can
define a machine location and I can use
this teach position to say hey I just
manually Park the turret in some
location if I'm happy and I know it has
full clearance to start spinning all my
tools I can just simply say teach
position and that will record wherever
the machine is physically sitting right
now or I can use positions relative to
work coordinates and just throw some
values relative to that I don't have any
real numbers in this machine so I'm just
going to throw in some simple offsets
but on the other physical machine to a
lot since I like use the Machine button
so it's a lot more permanent
location it's very visual next s one
that is a maximum rpm we're going to
allow the spindle to run at while doing
the part program so maybe I don't want
to go over 2,000 rpm safety how close do
I want to get to a part before I start
feeding so I'm going to let it come
within 50 tau and if I am doing milling
do I want to climb mill or conventional
mill tonight default to the climb mill
you don't have milling you won't even
see this option so you fill out the page
hit accept
and the event is step there
uh I just saw a question came in how do
you access this view I'm not sure which
are you he's speaking of Baretto if you
have an opportunity one with the block o
the block form I think you're talking
about so in the header it's right here
the blank
I believe that's what you are talking
about the block so that is just under
the blank field you can get to the block
for the block form great so this gives
us a good opportunity to to see how I
can make editing changes you know I had
accepted it and I have my event up on
the screen if you want to access that
event to make changes to it you simply
hit the blue arrow to the right gives
the event back come down to whatever
field you want to change hit accept and
it saves it so the first step in this
part of program just to show you guys
real quick to refresh your memory on the
shape we're going to face off the part
probably use an OD tool I take that same
tool come in and machine this OB and
then we'll calm until turning cycle and
few different things so my first step
would be to face off for part when
you're programming the highlight is
always going to be just above wherever
it's going to physically insert this
command so I always want to make sure
you keep your highlight above if you
have moved the highlight down to maybe
in program then you would have to move
it back up because it would tell you
that you're not allowed to insert after
that point so keep my highlight at the
top of my header I go over to turning
and turning you get an opportunity to
see a bunch of different cycles we have
for you in the control Tom time in
allowing I certainly don't have time to
go into every one but once you see one
or two if they're pretty
self-explanatory so the first cycle
we're going to use today is this common
rule cycle so that's just the cycle in
the upper right hand corner and what
stock removal allows me to do is it
allows me to take some multiple cuts
whether it be in the face or the OD or
the ID for any of these atypical shapes
so a standard square part with no
radiuses or chamfers
maybe a part that has some radius isn't
amperes in the corners a part that some
angles and radiuses and Jambres I can
you know define in the cycle if it's OD
or back turns you've been pretty
elaborate with the shape I'm going to
use this for facing so I'm just going to
do a basic basic standard no corner or
transfers or anything I'm going to first
select my tool so the first question the
system
well what tool by using it is retaining
the data from the last time the event
was program all of our fields or what we
call user definable meaning we don't
decide what your defaults are gonna be
they're just going to retain whatever
state you last left them in so in this
case I want to make sure I pick the
appropriate tool so I'm going to hit
this tool select key and that's going to
bring up a quick reference of my tool
table if I see the tool here great I
could just arrow up to that tool or pick
it in this case with my mouse or if I
maybe didn't see the tool here I may
want to hit the tool list button one
month time and it will put me all the
way back to the tool kit now in this
case I do see a little indicator here
that's just because that was the tool
that's staged at this point
so you highlight the tool just by moving
on highlight to that point and then
you're going to press the to program
button what that will do is that will
just fill out this field for you could I
have typed the name out absolutely but
when you start adopting our naming
terminology it gets kind of kind of
cumbersome to start typing in all of
these fields so that's why we have this
mechanism just tool select find the tool
say ok fills it out for me ok so I'm
using my seen mg degree diamond feed
rate can be defined as feed per Rev or
inches per minute I can toggle that I'm
going to keep it at feed per Rev I can
toggle between
rpm or constant surface feed just by
toggling I'm doing that with the Select
key
I can tell the Machine if I'm roughing
or finishing so I'm going to take
multiple passes or go right to these
dimensions where is my shape is it OD is
ID de spice in in a select key and
toggling through these couple of options
is it in my face or my turning this case
I want to face off so I'm going to click
face and then you give it your basic
dimensions so I said my rough stock was
two and a quarter from giving it my
rough stock a two and a quarter I said
that I was leaving 25 five of rough
material on the front so that's where my
z0 isn't starting for me but that way
for my part I'm going to end when I'm
done at the center of the part so this
is x1 is my ending diameter which is 0
because I want to face all the way to
the center of the part and when I'm done
I'm going to end at v-0 or c1 which is a
absolute position of 0 that's going to
be the face of my part and with the D I
can define my depth per passes so in
this case I'm going to take 15 pounds so
I'll take a 15th and then take whatever
is left over at the end for a final pass
then I can even leave a little material
for a finish cut in the U field u XR u z
whenever you see u that means finish
stock so you fill out a page and long as
you did everything properly you'll have
the accept key now if you put a funny
value let's say in this case the feed
rate is too long what will happen is
you'll lose the accept key so you can
proceed to the next step and will even
tell you right above the Edit key what
we think is going on so in this case
it's pretty straightforward feeds too
large up I use the half-inch per Rev
that's quite a bit I'll drop it down I
see the accept key and I'm good so
usually if you get to this point you're
pretty close certainly we don't
necessarily know what you know if you're
dimensions are correct but the base
structure of the cycle is correct at
this point if I wanted to simulate just
to get an idea of what's going to happen
I can simply hit my simulation button
and I'll see this tool come down and
just base off my part so this gives you
your first opportunity to see the
graphics tool comes down
my show path turned on so I see it come
down and face off a couple pieces I can
toggle that on or off by hitting in the
double arrow key on my verticals and
just hit show path or not
I'm going to back out I want to continue
out of the program I simply put the edit
button or simulation again either one
will take me out puts me back to my
editor and now in this case we're going
to continue to move on so if we look at
the shape one more time
I can see that I faced up the part to
size and now I want to create this
contour so I'm going to go in and I'm
going to actually draw this con from now
in this contour I'm going to start right
at the one-inch diameter and put this
little chamfer here
then I'll feedback I'll come down
through this field
so you'll notice dimensionally on this
detail I don't know some absolute
position but I roughly know how far in
this reliefs going and what we're back
at least before my arc starts and then
I'll feet up and feet around you
different things going on in this part
so what I want to do is I want to go to
our contour turn functions and I see
that button right to the right of
turning to get to irregular shapes so
the turning handles all my standards so
turning grooving all my simple shapes
square shapes one more when I get to any
irregular shapes I'm going to use the
contour turn function within this I can
do basic stock removal a basic turning
or OD or ID that's all set up right
within this cycle so you're going to get
a chance to see this cycle here but we
also can do irregular grooving or with
the plunge turning cycle we can do
regular regular bi-directional turning
so if you take a look here I'll come
down to the help screen
so here the tool would feed in veto over
feed down feed over and machine the part
was like a groove turn a combination
tool but what we're going to do is we're
going to do simple stock removal now
when you get to these irregular shapes
first thing you always need to do is
draw the shape and that's why the first
button in the upper right hand corner is
called new contour I select new contour
and we type in the name of the contour
so I'm just going to call something
simple OD once I've typed the name of
the contour I'm now just going to start
to give it some some elements or
describe the shape so these I'm getting
right off the print I said that I was
starting or I had a diameter of 1 inch
and d0 that's going to be where my
thread starts I do have a chancer that
leads it from the face
so I can tell this this is a transition
to the start of the element and I can
tell the chamber size I select accept
and I now see the first point sitting
out one inch now you're going to use
these icons on the right side to kind of
draw the shape so I'm pulling back so
I'm going to say the minus one on my
part I don't have anything happening
when it gets the end of that cause I'm
going to go into that that relief so I'm
going to simply hit accept now I see my
first chamfer my move back now it's
drawing up top above this zero because
this again is a rear turret machine if
this was a front turret or front tool
post machine you would see this would be
a mirror image of itself it would be
drawing on the bottom side so it's
always going to represent where the tool
is so what I want to do that relief I'm
now going to go into a two axis move by
hitting the X button and now we're going
to give it some information so if you
look real quick on my relief detail I
see that I'm going to move in
incrementally 90 sow and move over
incrementally two hundred thousand so
though that's the data that I'm going to
give it I'm going to come in and I'm
going to toggle with the select key both
of these fields to be incremental and
you can mix and match these both numbers
don't have to be incremental you can
have one implemental or absolute well as
I said we're moving in ninety thousand
we're moving over minus 0.2 it
calculates out the angles for that
location I hit accept
there's my chamber in now my next move
I'm going to do this as an arc so I'm
going to simply pick the arc event to
find the direction of my art give it the
radius and happen to know radius is an
eight point one two five any of the
fields will support math so I could type
in eighth and hit my input key on my
keyboard my Enter key and figures it out
I look at the end point on the print now
if it wasn't that clear so it didn't
know I don't know where the end point of
the arc is an X but I do know in Z up
against that wall
so that will happen to Ben at minus one
point 375 I don't know the absolute
center of the arc but I do know that the
arc is tangent to the previous element
so by simply hitting this tangent this
tangent trans button that's telling us
hey this arc the tangent to that
previous line now in this example I see
two different little dots I have this
orange arc and if I hit the dialogue
select button in the upper right hand
corner I can get a small portion of the
arc or a big Persian so when it
mathematically calculated this it says
well based on the end point that he told
me of inch and 3/8 I could be going
through that and hitting the intersect
new york a second time with that line a
second time or it can be stopping the
minute I hit that line so in this case I
want to stop and then I hit the lawn so
I'm going to pick the shorter of two so
my smaller segment is aren't and then
just simply hit delilah except if you
pick the wrong feature you can always go
change selection get right back to it
and select a different one so I've came
in I selected those points I'm now going
to accept it I have my arc from here
we're going to walk around the rest of
so the part I happen to know move
out to a one point seven fifty diameter
now at the end of that move it does have
a radius so I'm going to use the end of
corner function and tell it I'm going to
blend the radius to whatever comes next
I won't see that radius here until I
give it my next move which my next move
happens to be going back to one-inch 750
so now I see the radius come in and go
back to 1 and 750 now we're going to do
a two axis move to axis move is going to
go to a diameter two and a quarter in
this case and I'm just getting these
numbers right off my print - 2
from there I'm going to come back along
the part mile I park length and a two
and a quarter but I'm going to part it
off I'm going to want to go a little bit
beyond it so I don't leave a ridge or a
radius so I'm going to say go to minus
two point three if it except now there's
a big question do I want to end at this
point or do well maybe I want to do a
pull off move I can end at this point if
I'm happy with this but the only thing
you want to understand you have to be
aware of is the tool is going to come up
and along the surface cutter comp is
automatically enabled it also do any
fancy things to trim it out but since
the system is going to see this to be
the last move it's going to
automatically go beyond that point by
the radius of the cutter in this case 30
file as long as I know that's not going
to tential II hit anything I'm good I'm
clear I can I can stop right now if you
want to make sure that the system isn't
going to collide into my Chuck drawers
or anything next coming beyond this you
know that I can't let this cutter go any
further past that just do one final move
off on the X and then I'm trying to get
this shape so we're going to now it
except because the shape is not done you
see the contour is there there's this
little open-ended bracket that tells us
it needs a little more information so
now I'm going to decide which site one
so in this case I'm using my stock
removable side pool come in stock
removal I'm going to flip this to
roughing I'm going to go get my tool do
I have to give it my tool each time I
come in here no fools are modal so I
could leave a blank if I want I give it
some speeds give it some feeds drop
finger finishing my on the outside
inside and by cutting the phase am i
following a contour but do a bunch of
different stuff turning or facing
outside or inside depth per pass how
much material I will leave for a finish
cut now you'll notice I left this as a
single diamond that just means Rock if I
change it to a triple it'll just finish
or if I do a diamond plus a triple it
will rough and finish with the same tool
I don't want to do that I actually want
to go with back with a different tool
and finish it so I'm just going to wrap
up so the material I leave here the ten
thousand five file will not be taken off
until I'm until I come in with a
finishing operation di is kind of a neat
deal that's called an interrupted feed
so here I can give this system a linear
distance and once it comes that distance
it will cause the circle enough to break
the chip so kinda like a Peck drilling
cycle so let's say I tell it you know
point to 50 so it's moving in Z every
250 is going to just stop the servo not
the brake and chip and then continue but
break with gummy materials BL is what
controls my blank or what I'm really
machining from a lot of people think
that I'm machining from the solid I set
up in the header if you're not solid
header page is just simulation this
right now is what controls where the
Machine starts machining from so a
simple cylinder is saying hey look at
the shape that I just drew and I'm just
going to assume or I'm going to be
machining a basic bar type of routine
like you see in the graphic and I can
apply a little bit of additional
material outside of the shape if I
wanted to start machining away so if I
leave these two values at 0 0 it's going
to simply cut based on the shapes that I
drew if I want to start further out
maybe all of a sudden my stop change I
don't have to go change my headers or
anything on stuff I'm just going to move
this one number out with it that's being
said however I can also do allowances so
if you have a pre machine part or cast
part I can just tell it how much
material there is based off the shape
and it'll just machine where it needs to
or you can get it as elaborate as
drawing a separate contour to represent
the stop and again the machine will just
machine where it needs to machine so
have contours or have cast parts I can
do that by using a contour feature in
our case we're going to do a simple
cylinder
relief cuts do I want the system to go
in and try to turn that relief well I'm
going to let it try to turn that tool
we're going to see what happens so I'm
going to say yes you can try to go into
any relief what feedrate do I want to
come into it and the final question in
this cycle is do I want to limit it
limiting allows you to reduce the amount
you're machining by creating kind of a
box so a good example of this is let's
say we had a large bar with a steady
rest on the line and I drew the whole
shape but I can only go really a foot
back not the two feet I drew you could
create a box and it would not go
anywhere further than the provisions of
that box we don't need to worry about it
we'll leave it at now I select accept
now if we go simulate you're going to
start to see where we start to come in
and cut with this part now keep an eye
on when we try to go into the relief on
this operation you'll notice that I get
a small diagonal move in you always have
insert checking a gastric Technic navel
the system is never going to over cut
what it can with that physical tool so
you'll get as much as you can and now
it's going to leave this material for
you to figure some other way certainly
this wasn't a lot of material I might
just going to finish cycle and let my
finishing tool take it all out another
option may be would be pick a different
tool to rough work maybe I want to run
with a 55 not an 8000 or if you have the
option and this is an option in our
control you can use a function called
residual material what residual material
does is it gives me the ability of going
and picking a different tool so I'm
going to pick my 55 degree tool give it
some feeds and speeds just like you saw
before some cutting parameters like
depth of cod finish your mounts once I
hit accept it's going to say okay I'm
going to figure out everywhere that CMG
could not fit and then go in and machine
it with this dmg so you're going to see
the system automatically figures out
that I'm roughing tool couldn't fit here
so let me go in there with this
finishing tool and just get that a
portion
so it really if you do a lot of regular
shapes it allows you to quickly and
proficiently handle areas where the
cutters can't fit as well with that I'm
going to want to go back to the turning
cycle go back to stock removal in this
case I'm going to go to a finish because
I want to come in and take that final
finish material out and since I left the
tool blank it's going to finish with my
dmg so one final simulation on that and
you're going to see the shape now I can
go into 3d if I wanted to simulate it in
full 3d you can rotate and pan what
kinds of crazy stuff zoom in there's
physical keys to do all of this I'm just
using my mouse because I'm cheating but
you have a lot of different controls as
to how you're looking at a physical
shape I'm just using the side view right
now okay
the next operation looking at our part
print we've turn the whole thing I want
to put the thread on so we're going to
put a thread on it we're going to drill
a hole and we're going to part it off so
as far as it's read remember my
highlight I'm always inserting below so
I just leave the highlight on this last
line I did I'm going to jump over to
turning and then I'm going to go into
the threading cycle by picking the
threading button from vertical in
threading I'm going to pick a tool I
already created tool this was a like a
top notch style kind of mental tool I
can define a table if I want to pick up
a specific table or I can just tell it
that I'm going to define the thread as
either a pitch mobile command
millimeters or threads per inch and in
inch mode if you do that and your pitch
is changing over the length of thread
and tell it that and it'll change we
also support taper threads any of these
cycles can support OD or ID base threads
and even call chain threads where the
pitch can change and the shapeable
thread can change
over the course of the part we're doing
standard straight threading so I define
in this case I'm doing an eight-pitch
now we have the fraction if you're not
using the fraction you cancel the
fraction out just by giving it like a
simple zero over eight one side I tell
it the RPM now one thing we can do that
it's very unique in our system is you
and read in either rpm or constant
service feed it is dependent on the
Builder whether they support this or not
but the control absolutely does support
threading in constant service fee the
other thing you can do in our controls
is we do variable speed threading where
you can adjust your spindle speed live
while you're cutting the thread we do
not cap this middle speed feed rate
obviously is a function of the pitch so
that doesn't matter where you leave it
it's 100 during the thread but the
spindle override is absolutely live some
builders will will not allow this
functionality based on their performance
of their machines but as far as the
control is concerned it can absolutely
is a standard function allow you to
adjust your spindle override Wallen
thread you can do depressive or linear
cuts the rest of its going to reduce the
cut forecast so they get it to keeper in
OD your ID and then you just fill out
the dimensions of red so what's the OD
where is it start where does it end how
much advance do I want to give it so you
know usually I'll use about one thread
wrap so like kind of a pitch thread that
one you know I might want to give it
just about know just about one thread
pitch for its its start so it means it's
going to start heart out away from the
part lr do I want to do a champ or
leading out I said it's a zero it's
going to cut as much as as far as you
can and then wrap it to clear the back
of overall what's the thread height
what's my in feed angle and this ap can
be toggled between a an angle or a value
I like to set it as an angle and right
now I'm using a thirty degree angle
first cut depth how much material am i
leaving for finish pass number of spring
cuts I want to back off Villar so I pull
off usually like this to be a little
higher than that red light it's not
really all that critical so it's the
value off the major am i doing multi
lead threads yes or no and how many
leads and then do I want to control my
starting angle mantra so if I need it to
time the thread in relation to something
anchored I fill out the event it stores
it in this case I'm going to maybe go in
and drill the hole so I can jump over to
drilling now if your machine does not
support milling tools or live tools the
only button you're going to get is
drilling central because that means I'm
drilling basically always in the center
of the part if you have live tooling and
we'll go into live tooling in a later
seminars in our series then you'll get
start to leverage some of these live
tool functional so in this case we're
just going to do a simple drilling
centric you can do drilling or tapping
within this drilling centric it
automatically supports chip record chip
removal in cycles but if you don't want
to Peck drill you just create it where
your depth in your impact for the same
value and you're drilling it you fill
out the page hit accept
now we have the drilling cycle now in
the drilling cycle we do have the
ability of compensating for the tip or
the shank of the tool so like in this
case I told it go to 25 to 2 inch to 25
to incorporate is because when you
create a drill you also tell the tip
angle okay then my final function is
going to be a part off function so I'm
then going to go back to turning select
the cut off option and then filling out
this page so in this case I'm going to
select my plunge cutter and when you're
creating grooving tools you'll not only
tell it your standard information like
the corner break because we can profile
and finish with the cutter you're going
to give it the insert with and then a
rough length of the overall interval the
answer lines not that critical
it's a width that's obviously critical
because the system going to
automatically compensate for the
backside of that tool you don't have to
do it it won't figure it out for you but
you got to give it the appropriate width
right here from there
give it some feed rate since middle
speed the maximum rpm I'm allowing the
physical spindle to go because in this
case I happen to be running constable
feet apart off where I'm not what's the
OD and what's the total length of the
part it'll automatically and the insert
width to this value because it knows
that this is this is a part off part I
can plug in a chamfer or a radius FS
represents chamfer and then if that was
an R that would be erased yes so I was
doing 50 thou Schamberg back on my part
this is not kind of nice this is our
reduce speed and feed for our part off
so you know we've all been that scenario
where I'm coming flying down the part
and it pops and it's going real fast and
flies across my shop or misses my part
capture so this is saying at what
diametric location do you want to now
slow down the spindle and slow down the
feed rate so here I'm getting to be to
an eighth inch diameter I'm then telling
it I want to reduce my feed rate I want
to reduce my spindle to a straight rpm
and given rpm and then where do I want
to end at the very end of the portal
cutoff cycle so you fill out the page
you hit accept cutoff cycles here so now
we have the program part so I do a final
simulation and you would just keep
adding obviously operations as you go on
your specific Jones the mechanisms
really would want to kind of gain from
here so we rough it out we finish it
tool comes in threads it
then you guys see the drill come and
drill it and we part it off if I'd like
to see the internal see that drill I can
go to further views and select F button
ooh and then I'll give us a sectional
view you can have this up so you know I
could have had that while I was
machining the entire part and then I
could see the cutter come in you can
control the speed at which simulates by
going to program control then you either
using the overrides up or down or just
sitting on a percent it's nice because
you can really gain a lot of control
when you're simulating so you know if I
slow it way down I can really start to
see what's happening really here I can
go five percent feed you can you know
cycle stop you can reset you can do a
whole bunch of things now this is all
independent of the machine running an
auto you can do all this functionality
while it's cutting another part so you
can concurrently program comparing to
simulate all this stuff while it's doing
another task okay so from here back in
in our presentation the last section I'd
like to talk about we'll just take a
look at it pretty quickly because we are
getting a little late on time is our
auto mode so auto mode is the area I
would physically go to run up our
program so some of the things we'll talk
about as we'll talk about our basic
blocks field or distance to go field
bringing up simulation in auto mode you
can use the same simulation but that's a
current simulation to where you are
maybe starting in a little program how
would I start at some point program so
when we we look at auto mode first thing
is how do I get into auto well one of
two ways to get in total I can access
order right now by hitting the execute
button in the lower right corner or back
in my program manager I could hit the X
cube on the upper right both functions
will do the same thing what they'll do
is they're going to put me into auto
there I see I'm in auto I left my
spittle running the whole time
put me into auto and loaded the tool see
sample ones or loaded the program into
memory sample ones already here it's
active I didn't have to do that as a
separate step it's all automatic by just
saying I am I'm in this program or I'm
highlighting this program we're gonna
kill it I want to execute if I had just
hit the radio button for auto then it
would have went into auto with whatever
the last program or if there was no last
program just a blank oil area so I do
have to physically either go into the
program or use execute from program
manager to get in now you do want to be
aware of where the highlight is because
this is one way to start in the middle
of program so while I left my highlight
on cut off and I wanted to execute it
automatically stages and tells me that
block search mode has been activated so
if that was a mistake because I really
just want to start beginning simply at
the reset key and it will rewind the
program if you really want to start from
there certainly I could hit cycle start
a little slower if I'm started in the
beginning it's simple right now
initiating cycle start it would start
machining my part I can certainly
control with my overrides how fast to go
now let's say I want to see that all the
results of these different cycles well
if you hit basic blocks it brings up all
of the resulting lines a lot of people
they get concerned when they see
conversational type of programs because
they don't really they don't get a good
idea of where the machine's going to
next with recyclable one just hit your
basic blocks and we'll bring it up do
you have a timer parts counter so it
will give you cycle time time remaining
you can do workpiece count if you want
to in this way it will track your
different work pieces where you are in a
production run that kind of stuff you
can control the system in a program
control so a program control allows me
to maybe enable optional stops PRT is in
an axis lock mode so the system will run
but the server's won't really move dry
run I want to run it I don't even a part
in there I just want to run it in the
air real fast I can initiate dryland
Road
our our g0 rapid reduce rapid travels so
let's say I got a new machine or a
really fast machine improving on a part
and the rapid search is too quick I can
select that you'll see the little RG
zero whenever any of these are active
because you know panel may not always be
up but doesn't mean they're not active
so right now I know dry run is on say C
gry and I know the rapid reduction is on
so if I come back into it I can toggle
on or off single blocks by single block
modes we have a couple different modes
the two most popular or rough and fine
so single block fine is what we're all
kind of used to that means every time
I'm going to do execute some kind of
move over command I got a hit single
block single block rough will allow non
motion commands to pass through will
allow can cycles to to kind of go
through so like if I'm in the middle of
a Peck drilling cycle it'll allow the
Peck drilling cycle to complete but not
all not move to the next location let's
say until a head cycle start again so
that gets kind of Handy so they've done
a bunch of different ways for me to
control how the machine is going to
react if I want the simultaneous record
on I pickup simultaneous record that's
going to bring the graphics now when I
initiate cycle start I'll physically see
the cutter and it's a real time
certainly in simulation runs a little
quicker or shall I say the senior
training mode runs a little bit quicker
than it normally would in the real world
but you can see that this functionality
would allow you to start to see what's
happening on the machine at the same
time as running it okay so we covered a
lot of material in certainly a short
time I appreciate everybody hanging on
there I want to now open things up to
our Q&A panel so we do have the chat
window but sometimes it's easier if you
guys use the Q&A panel for me too so any
new questions that you guys are going to
pose if you go up to a little pulldown
toolbar and see Q&A just click on it
type the type of question in and then we
can start to talk about some of this
stuff
ah
[Music]
so with that being said let's open up
the floor to any questions so we have
our first question in is it possible to
convert a shop term program to AG code
program or vice versa no it is not so
shop term programs will only solely be
shop term programs you can certainly
bring abrasive blocks like I showed you
to see the resulting quotes but it in
our scenario on when we build shop turn
we built it at the same time really as
building the program guide in this
interface so it wasn't like an ant on
piece of software where we had to
translate out because in the back end
we're really still trying to run an G
code this is just a way for us to kind
of build the g-code file so with that
we've never created the Mechelen
mechanism to be able to take a
conversation file import it to just a
simple native G code at the end of the
day in the back end it's really running
these cycles so that's it's not like
we're translating in the back room so no
you can't port it out the G code now
when you get to our G code section what
you do have the ability is standard in
our G code so if I had written a G code
program we sorry about that let me type
in a name here and just give some simple
name we automatically have
conversational sport in G code program
guide comes standard and has had this
functionality for for 20 years
so when I'm writing a g-code file I fill
out the page conversationally I see the
cycle so in the control I can always
open up any cycle whether it's created
from a cam system or it was physically
written at the control I can open it up
conversational a lot of guys you know a
lot of a lot of builders try to leverage
what we would call cycle support as
conversational program and it really is
not true conversational is true
conversational entire length of the
program quick and conversational cycle
support is a standard feature in our
control that's right in program guide so
you get that for all of your canned
cycles hopefully that that answered your
question
so we got a few more questions came in
here let me just expand my panel a
little bit Norman on orem blyer joining
us hello Norman
before I end comment on what Siemens is
showing at IMTS especially what might be
new absolutely so those who may not be
aware the umps show out in Chicago is
going to be happening in a couple weeks
I'm 22 weeks awards and a scramble time
we're going to have four machine tools
in our booth we're going to have a new
8:28 that supports two channels with a
sub spindle so that's definitely new we
have more demos and new added features
on the my robot functionality one of the
big things we've been doing as of late
is handling robotic part loading right
inside the control so instead of having
to have a separate robotic control with
its own programs to handling your work
loading and unloading and report loading
we can do that as a separate channel
right internally in our control so all
your programs for loading and unloading
can be right next to your park programs
you're actually making the parts so
that's some of the new stuff as well as
a whole host of other different things
that we're going to have there Michael
has a question here seem to have trouble
toggling between incremental and
absolute but once I input my coordinate
value a once I implement coordinate I
had to delete my numbers well sometimes
what can have a mindful is especially if
there was mathematic calculation applied
that one number I input maybe then
affecting other values so then by trying
to change it back it doesn't want you to
do that primarily because it is there
was manned applied to that field so kind
of what we're talking about here is if
we go into our sample we go into our
contour and you know I'm in some shape
and I say okay I want to I want to now
make this a incremental value says it
rejects it I have a feeling that this is
probably what you're seeing
well that's because that number was
highly dependent on all these numbers
being calculate so in that scenario I
yes I would want to delete the number
and then I can flip it incremental and
put in a correct number Steve what does
the various key function do so this is
the various button on our keyboard right
next to our increments allows me to
create like a variable so not various
but variable for my increment or job so
when I'm out a machine right now I'm in
job if I want to you know if I'm moving
some fine location I can drop the
machine based on a value right so here I
have 10 for for 100 is going to be 100
or 10,000 to be
settings so I'm expanding my soft keys
over on the machine tool you would do
this with the right arrow button
generally next to the menu select key I
access settings and I can now go in and
I have an option for variable so we
could create now there there is PLC
logic involved with this so not all
builders support it you see if the
simulator does so I put a value here and
now it should allow me to it doesn't
look like I have the PLC logic should it
should allow me to that you know jog it
and that variable value so that's where
it kind of comes in okay is it better to
always run a program from the NC memory
or is it not important run from a local
drive are there any recommendations
regarding the use of a different memory
for CN and local Drive that's a great
question
as far as running programs in our system
you can certainly run from any source
and generally the only limitation on
large files is sometimes the buffer when
you're viewing the program in our auto
mode it might not show you quite as much
of the program but that is something
that we've made great strides with
operate to be able to support some of
the older systems and the pre operating
systems you lost some functionality so
the core program does run but maybe we
couldn't edit or if we did allow editing
simulation wouldn't work now we've
really opened up a lot of those
restrictions so pretty much we can care
less where the program resides with that
though when using a USB I always warn
people to not make that a normal
practice and for two primary reasons one
it's not a very secure connection
certainly anybody come in and pop the
thing right out always in the middle of
running or you know just in jiggling
it's not a great connection but even
probably more than that there's a lot of
garbage USB sticks on the market so you
know hey I got this free on open my bank
account that's what
run $100,000 machine tool so with that
said you know use it if you get in a
bind and you want to run something USB
absolutely but don't make it a normal
process we have from Robert are you
doing Robert
what is sync thread is a thread report
pair absolutely sync thread is our
thread repair function so the old
systems pre operate you used to have to
go into the can cycle and that was where
we had the the mechanism for you to
actually align more spindle to your tool
because that's really what you're doing
when you're doing a drug repair now we
add it as a function and the function is
within job so I expand my soft keys over
when I see this link thread function so
in sync thread I come in I tell it that
yes I want to sync to my primary spindle
certainly I could have multiple spindle
sports if I main spindles on spindle and
then you would physically move the tool
over just like see the image and engage
the thread into one of the leads of the
throw once you're there all you have to
do is simply to teach spindle and it
will now orient the spindle to that tool
from here I can immediately go back and
like what see the our program running
and now the tools timed so even if I was
in the middle of a production run and
pull the port out gauged it was no good
I just come back into this function and
run now you certainly have to make sure
the court is still in its original Z
location so I'd either set a new Z
through length offset or maybe bumps cut
off the part or something and this is
what times the spindle to that physical
tool great question book okay well that
was it was great I got a a lot of
questions here just looking over just to
see looks like I got everybody hopefully
I did
all right Oh Danny I put one thing for
Norman another thing that we will be
talking about a little bit at the show
is additive machine practices and we are
going to have a I don't know if we have
one in the booth or not forgive me I
don't remember if the dmj machine in the
booth is going to be showing at it
machine no dmg will have additive
machining and their group running from
our control additive machining something
we haven't been quite a bit with with
some of the high-end buildings okay
so if if that's pretty good I think
we're right on the minute here for an
hour and a half looks like we needed all
of it thanks everybody for attending I
will certainly send out an email
everybody sure XIV a thank you email for
attending with the link to the
recordings again I will send out
invitations for the next one so
hopefully everybody found this helpful
and we can continue this in the future
great I'm going to end our recording
here and it is very typical
functionality that you would always do
through an MDI screen in a control but
by creating this simple little interface
screen it keeps the users from having to
know and learn all these heavy-handed
commands so if I want to do something as
simple as just physically change my tool
now if I look at the tsf window the tsf
window is just a quick representation
what's active at this point in the
control so it knows that I have some
punch better physically loaded maybe
some fees or some spindle speed states
so if I simply come down and I can move
my highlight around with my blue arrow
to my tool field I can now hit the
Select tool key in the upper right hand
corner and get access to my tool table
so my tool table is showing me all the
different tools that are physically
loaded in the machine horrible so let's
say we wanted to spin tutor position
number one and bed to our CNM G 432 or
our 80 degree OD rocking tool I can
simply highlight that tool by moving up
with the blue arrow keys select okay
machine filled out the name of my tool
and now it's just waiting for simple
cycle style by pressing cycle start will
initiate a tool change automatically
important so the machine now would do
anything the builder prompted or wanted
it to do for torturing to it has to go
to a read track location go to that
retrack location if they're just
allowing the third to spin at that point
it would do that but you'll notice in
the TFS screen I now see my new tool
loaded in my turn so it's fun to that
position would have loaded any offsets
that may be set for that tool and I can
now continue moving on that tool I'll
use this for maybe turning my spindle on
so let's say for argument's sake I want
to start up my main spindle at five
hundred rpm and I want to give it a
direction I'm going to use my select key
to define some kind of a direction so
maybe I want to clockwise and now I'm
going to simply hit the cycle start key
and you'll see I spin a little turn on
my feedback will even show me that the
spindle is now spinning everything is
running so these are the typical steps I
would use to spin the turret to some
location fire my spindle and get ready
for maybe setting a tool setting an
offset as well if I wanted to load up a
work coordinate I could come in select a
specific work coordinate that I want to
use that I'm going to activate from
setting zeros cycle start and that would
initiate loading of that work or
anything within the GSM screen will
require a physical cycle start to then
activate I can also use this to maybe
turn Mike's middle back off if I wanted
to but using the X with the circle
through it it's like we're starting that
command spindle tool so you'll use the
TSM screen to do a lot of your standard
manual functions from there let's say I
wanted to jog the Machine around so I
can jog utilizing my axes right here so
I pick a given axis I can select the
plus or minus key I can start to move
the machine around maybe I want to move
Z so I select thee you'll notice this
has a y axis plus about other axes
certainly this machine could support
many axes this one's just commissioned
for a couple this was built to support C
axis capability in live tooling we won't
be going through that today but we could
in the future absolutely so with that
being said maybe I want to come in and
set a tool offset very common occurrence
that you'll find yourself doing when
setting up a job for a lathe well
certainly the first step would be load
the actual tool that I want to set you
know potentially turn my spindle on to
some direction because I'm going to come
in pick a little light pad or whatnot
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use this measure tool function
so a measure tool allows us to come in
and set our tool offsets so once I
select the measure tool button is
selected by going blue I just clicked on
that button I can now pick in the upper
vertical soft keys are operating in
corner the manual or the automatic
buttons so manual would be benefitting
come in and manually set this tool
probably take a light color on a piece
of material automatic would be if I had
a preset or what's a machine so we're
going to go through just manually
setting a tool today I select the manual
function you'll see that the tool is
already pre-selected it knows what's in
the third or what's loaded so it
automatically defines that I would then
probably you know jog machine or annular
machine to some location come in take a
light cut we would go down measure up
our part maybe my cup that diameter and
then I would tell the system in the x0
field what is the diameter I'm
physically sitting at so you usually
take a cot mover straight back and Z
leaving the X is still aligned with that
edge shut the spindle off measure it
maybe we found that we were at two and a
half inches I simply type the diametric
value to point five this is well
automatically cut that in half for you
and then I merely type it in and then
press the SEC length function so before
I hit it I want you to take a look at
our work field the work field is
displaying our absolute positions
relative to some offsets from zero
so see how it's sitting at twenty three
point six eight right now we hit set
length and all of a sudden it applies to
two point five in our control whenever
you set any offsets we will immediately
load those offsets same scenario if I
was to adjust the offset maybe by
climber where so we were running this
tool we wanted to maybe go to the offset
table go to my where field and tell it
that I'm maybe I was a little big so I
want to reduce the offset by five bow
well if I come back out you notice I
didn't physically do anything with the
tool or move the machine but immediately
it's reflecting that also so whenever
you're setting any offsets you always
want to verify as long as that's the
tool that's called up or the work one is
called up that the display physically
change if it didn't you need to stop and
kind of go back and figure out maybe
what you did wrong as to why that tool
didn't properly update or that it also
didn't update so in this case Z if it
came over to the light cut in the face
of the part I could tell it zero I could
tell it some small positive negative
distance depending on where I'm setting
it but I did the same process I give it
a value and hit set length my offsets
change now you're going to do a lot with
measure tool because you have a lot of
tools to set up typically in the lathe
so here I can stay within this screen so
let's say I were to move back move out a
little bit now I want to change to some
other tool well if you have arrow back
up to the T field in the measure tool
field we can initiate tool changes just
like the TSN screen you just saw so here
I hit select tool we can maybe arrow
down to our finish cutter say okay that
tool name is now loaded we'll talk about
tool names and a little bit facing tools
but the tool is physically loaded now I
just have to execute it by hitting a
cycle start you see now loads the new
tools my offsets change because I don't
have an offset yet for them now I would
repeat the same process
I would potentially jog down over some
look
maybe will Z and then give the machine
till it whatever axis some setting it
will retain the value so if I'm just
going to touch a lot on to a predefined
axis value I don't have to keep typing
them each time then I just say set
length for each of them and I've just
established offset so just follow that
pulses the graphics will update
depending on the tool that you selected
so you know if you go to drill and then
mills you'll see it'll update to reflect
that and try to give you a little better
process of what we'd be expecting you
would do to set this tool generally
there's a lot of different ways to set
up blades generally you know a lot of
guys like to set up all their tool
offsets either to a Bix datum or to
maybe just the part and then they'll
adjust all the tools by applying some
value in a record so in our machine you
can do that by simply going in I'm just
going to put that turning tool we had in
before back in we're simply going to my
measure workpiece field measure
workpiece allows me to move over to some
location so maybe I was to move to some
position now this is let's say where I
wanted to set a work coordinate value so
what the work order value would do a
little move all it will the same amount
so if I had pre-established maybe all of
my tools to the base of my chocolate set
and I want it to now move over just one
given tool touch the front of my new
part and then have all the tools set
there this would be a good example of
where I would use my measure workpiece
field I would move the machine back
touch a physical part select whichever
work coordinate I want to work I want to
use tell it what I want this value to be
so maybe I'm hitting a one to three
block use a paper shim stock I could
tell it may be a small value from there
hit set work coordinate you see ma my
display changes now that value didn't
change for the tool offset it actually
applied to the work coordinate so we'll
go in to look at the offset table normal
second and you'll see where some of
these values grow as well other common
things you can do
the job screen will be maybe position
the Machine around so here I can tell to
you know pika some location maybe I
wanted to go to an X of 2 inches cycle
start machine would run and do that as
commanded feed move and do rapid moves
here so you can just kind of move the
Machine around its work envelope this
way we give you a basic stock removal
screen this is a simple can cycle that
allows you to do a basic simple stock
removal so if you wanted to turn some
soft gels like today and you know maybe
I'm going to work on an ID set of soft
rolls I wouldn't have to write a whole
program I can fill out this one little
event once I fill it out and I have good
numbers here then you will get the
accept key and once it's happy this
becomes a little program so I could go
and hit cycle start and this program
should run I didn't give it any valid
numbers but it's a just quick snip away
from able to do some basic like that and
depending on the machine tool you've
purchased and how the Builder is
configured it we may bring up a lot of
these different hand cycles up on the
screen a lot of our teach lays engine
lanes that have the ability of running
on a manual and CNC like hybrid machine
they'll give you a whole bunch of
different camp cycles up in this mode
and they I will work kind of the same
way now what we want to look at here as
well we were kind of moving the Machine
around and jogging around setting pull
off sex I do want to show you the offset
screen briefly so in the offset screen
I'm going to get there by getting my
hard offset button I will see our tool
table and the tool table is a physical
tool list the tool list is going to
contain the tool the offsets and some of
the geometry that makes up the given
tool tool where is just how I can adjust
small incremental values aware I also
have my tool life management here
magazine is more reserved for machines
with like milling machines with random
tool changes and Parham cells and
whatnot but you do have the ability of
that functionality here as well with
more complex machine then offsets is
where all my work coordinate or work off
sensor seven
so if I come in and I look at my g54 I
can see where that number got inserted
when I did that or coordinate offset set
so just like when I set my clever pool
now these values are a distance from
some machine location potentially to
wherever I was setting the tool if I was
basically everything off of this the
gauge tool overworked coordinate then
these could potentially be just small
incremental values or some data to that
tip so with that being said let's say I
wanted to create a tool from scratch why
don't we build one at least so you can
see the mechanism certainly we don't
have enough time to build all the tools
for the whole part program but if we can
build one or two it will give you a
pretty good understanding of at least
the start of the mechanism so the way
tools work in the Siemens world is
you're going to potentially have tools
sitting in a physical location this
would be a position or that is
physically loaded in the machine or they
can be in what we call an unloaded state
so we allow you to build or move tools
from inside of the machine tool through
outside locations just by being in a
loaded State meaning they have a
location to the Lampron or physically in
the machine or what we call an unloaded
state meaning that they still exist but
they don't exist in the machine some
builders force you to make tools that
are automatically in an unloaded state
and then go through loading process
other builders do not really up to the
Builder how he wants to set up the
machine so in this case let's say I'm
going to build a tool in an unloaded
state I could select new tool and now I
see a full tool library of different
tools we support we're initially just
looking at what we call our favorites
screen so this is some very common tools
you might want to use then you can go
into more detail tool doing all
different kinds of cutters right angle
heads and all sorts of different dime
old end mills and fall end mills drill
socials urban drills and taps we support
all kinds of been turning tools we do
special probes and start probes and stop
so the whole I would have to say okay
well I'll use offset 22
to match with long tulle one when I want
to use a have a dummy offset and have a
different offset in our world you simply
select the edges function and edges will
allow you to create a whole new offset
so all I do is I select new cutting edge
and now you see how I get a second one
now there's no number this doesn't mean
it's not loaded this just means that
these two are associated in the Siemens
world when you're dealing with multiple
cutting edges you will then get a new
number under your D field and this is
how it gets called up in the part
program
it's a D number from d1 through d9 so
you'll never see a d number larger than
9 that's the maximum number off since we
support and then from there it shows
match this number so this can be a
computing completely unique tool doesn't
even have to be the same visible tool
you know if I had a little gang tool
setup here and I knew that that I had a
turning tool a threading tool and a part
of wall on a little game setup I could
do that right now I could come in and
say okay well my second cutting edge is
going to be going to be a threading tool
or my second cutting edge is going to be
a part off tool now the one thing it
doesn't let me change is the name
because it's always linked to this
turret position so if only one name so
you might want to call it Universal or
something like that but now these
offsets are completely unique so there's
there's no Association in this case now
though I will see with instead of the
angle this is my insert with so if this
was a 100 dollar wide grooving tool I
would just type point 1 here or whoops
excuse me I would type point one for my
grooving tool width and that would be
some of the parameters you just for
grouping tool ok so we are now going to
jump back over to our power point here
for a second and we're going to take a
look at the next area we're going to
explore in this this
so for next thing we want to talk about
is our program manager so you can start
to see some of the functions you can
start to use to set up a job Jud job
machine around and create some tools the
program manager is an area for you to
manage the programs in the machine
you're going to get to the program
manager area by selecting the program
manager button that's typically a hard
key somewhere on your panel all of the
hard Keys can also be accessed via soft
keys by simply being the menu select key
so if you have some kind of a custom
front panel or whatnot which is very
common in our control you may want to
just find the menu select key once you
hit menu select you will see those soft
keys come up we'll look at that a second
example are the live portion of the demo
within program manager I'll get a list
of directories and areas where I can
start state programs so you take a look
at that I have the ability of creating
directories creating different types of
programs so you're going to get a chance
to see how to how to physically start
and initiate a shop term program
we can save set up data so all those
fields are features you saw within the
tool table can be saved as a physical
bottle so not only can you manage you
know part program specific to a job but
also the tool data that makes it up and
the full data is all the tools as well
as all the offsets all your consults as
well it can be saved so we can take a
peek at that and then from there once
we've created a part program we're going
to go in in this shop turn programming
inner things and we're going to start to
take a look at all of the different kind
of elements that make up a shop term
program so the first thing we'll see is
the program header that's always going
to be that first initial screen we
always see our starter program and
there's a bunch of basic parameters
we'll fill out in there and explain to
what they do then we're going to get to
the event editor and this is where we
actually start to give the program some
depth you know this is where we start to
tell the Machine what it's going to do
so we're going to first come into the
editor and it will basically be blank
and then we'll start picking the
operations using our software buttons
like drilling or turning to go to a
defined location or operation we'll get
a chance to see some of the canned
cycles in this job we're going to use a
basic turning cycle for facing and then
we're going to go into our contour
editor to machine in a regular shape
where then once we've programmed up the
part going to get a chance to take a
look at it in our 2d and 3d simulation
mode and we can start to look at cutter
paths and different features on the part
maybe look at three dimensions maybe cut
it to start to look at some of the
internal especially when you get to some
intricate internal work it's a nice way
to be able to see what's going on inside
of the part and that gives us now an
opportunity to go in and physically
explore some of these features so I'm
going to select send you train again
it's going to put us back over to the
Senya train portion of the looks into
this demo from here like I said I'm
going to use the program manager to get
the program manager this button will get
me right there but if you can't find the
button for some reason to simply find
wherever the menu school
Kia's menu select is always somewhere on
on the front of our panel that's a must
as far as all buttons there's usually
two you always see menu select and
machine menu select and then I could see
the difference soft buttons for so
program manager here there's the
software button for program manager
sometimes we change our names on a
physical function at the end of the day
as one of the icon matches so if you
look at the parameters button here the
second one over and you look at the
offset button the hard button pull
offset then you see that the same icon
goes this in place we just happen to use
a different name and the software button
menu down the heart button that's all
same thing with Diagnostics or alarm
same place baby alarm button it's going
to go to the alarm area if I hit menu
select it the diagnosis button goes to
the same area of the alarm so again you
can hit program manager to get there or
you can hit menu select and then program
monitoring you come in and this is the
program manager so this is where all of
our programs reside in the control what
you're first seeing is the NC directory
so this is you know active internal NC
memory in the machine within NC memory
we've kind of set it up to feel very
similar to like a Windows environment so
I make first come up and see my three
core folders our program sub programs
and work pieces I can use my blue arrow
to move my cursor up or down I can use
my right or my left arrow to expand or
compress different folders I'm going to
look at a large list with blue libraries
that are here for you
normally most of stuff you're going to
use is can be found under the favorites
screen so let's say for argument's sake
we were going to come in and create a
standard standard turning tool so maybe
it's going to be a roughing tool so I'm
going to leave the roughing tool
highlighted and then I have these
orientations now may be hard to see on
your end but if you look close you'll
notice that the first one has a little
orange tinge to it
orange compatible you know in relation
to the other tools
well I can move that orange highlight
around to each of these tools using my
arrow keys so this is how I define the
orientation of the tool how it sits in
the physical machine this machine is set
up as it was a slanted so this is a rear
turret so this first tool would
represent an OD tool if this machine was
a front turret machine then you would
see everything would get looked
backwards our icons our placement will
always represent or match the way the
machine was built so the first position
always represents ability tool but you
might see the icon would look like this
third one over here so what you'll do is
you'll kind of scroll through and you
have a whole bunch of I'm going to do
neutral tools and get all my different
orientations for my neutral tools we
have in this case eight different
orientations I can pick from so this one
I'm going to pick my first orientation
and I'm going to say okay now I happen
to have the naming automatically turned
on so it gave me a rough name and this
is probably one of the first things that
guys notice that's a major difference
from us to a lot of our competitors is
the fact that tools do not have to be
numbers and although they can be there's
nothing wrong with being a number but
you can call it anything you want I like
it because I can build in kind of user
comments or notes right into the name of
the tool so let's say for argument's
sake I wanted to build a 35 degree tool
I could tell it it's a mic capsule on a
V nmg and maybe it was a 3/32 insert I
see and radius and I happen to know that
that is an OD tool so this would be a
normal way for me to put in some
different information I have right in
the name of tool chipbreaker
you get pretty elaborately we support
quite a few quite a few characters
within a given name you type in the name
whatever you want letters numbers we
support anything you want there even you
see forward slashes and so in mine we
can do special characters you hit enter
and then it moves the highlight over to
the X length enter on the control would
also be the yellow in
button right here the length for X and
the length or Z will get filled out when
you do the set length functionality so
you don't have plain numbers in there
unless you happen to know your
presetting tools or have known data but
you can type them in directly the next
thing would be my radius I have a number
two R ads that would be no.31 radius so
I'm going to type it by primary cutting
direction now the system figured that
out based on the orientation I chose but
if I wanted to flip things around I
could change my primary cutting
direction certainly the two primaries
for this tool would either be down or to
the left you'll notice if I put the
wrong cutting direction we put a little
indicator here on the insert the same
things aren't quite driving so in this
case I'm telling it to have a
left-handed tool but cut to the right
which doesn't like that very much
so we'll do a standard left hand tool
color direction the next field is our
relief angle and that is basically my
clearance we look at this insert picture
to the top of the screen it's the
angular distance so it's always added
from 90 degrees so if I have a 5 degree
relief I'm going to put 95 but I have a
3 degree relief 93 7 is 97 so you're
just going to take 90 degrees and then
add whatever that relief angle is 2 we
have the insert physical little insert
angle I know this to be a 35 degrees
since there'd be an mg and then I have
the IC of the inserts we'll save it and
I see the IC is that inscribed circle in
the instrument so that's how we can kind
of understand how big the insert is from
there there's a couple extra fields you
have your standard cut direction for
this tool so if I was inverting the tool
or something like that I could flip it
over and then I have my physical
coolants and you may or may not see
multiple coolants it really kind of
depends on if the machine was built with
a couple different quotes so a lot of
times I'll just see one that'll be a
standard for one then maybe the second
to high pressure or washdown or
something along those Long's
so once that's all filled out I'm all
set my tool is created and defined I
have all the information I need tomorrow
now in this case the tool is unloaded so
we know it exists but it's not
physically in the machine so let's say
it's time to mount the tool and ruching
you want to put it in the machine I'm
simply going to make sure this tools
highlighted anywhere on this little
matter and then I'm going to use the
load button on my vertical soft keys
load allows me to say hey I'm going to
the machine right and where do I want to
put it so maybe I knew that I want to
put it in pocket 16 I type it in say ok
tool gets physically moved up do I now I
have to actually mount it fullness in
the turret absolutely this is just a
mechanism for us to manage the tools but
what's nice is if you guys are dealing
with a lot of tools you're breaking down
setups all the time you know I can come
in say hey I'm not using the create demo
right now but the tools still a valid
tool I'm potentially going to put it
back in the machine at some point so I
just highlight the tool select unload
and you'll see they didn't delete the
toilet and lose its data just sitting in
an unloaded State how many tools can I
support in this screen it's really after
the Builder it is builder selectable but
most the time I see most builders will
support 99 tools so it's however many
locations we have here and then the rest
of it till equals 99 but we can support
thousands of tools so it's really really
up to a function of the builder
now the other thing I do want to point
out when taking a look at tools in our
system is what we call multiple cutting
edges so in the Siemens world you can
actually create up to nine unique
offsets for any given tool typically
when using this type of functionality in
maybe some competitive controls you
would have had to sacrifice another
offset number to use to be able to do
this type of functionality so you know
maybe I had 99 offsets
so the recording shall have just
initiated thanks again everybody for
attending this is easy C&C with shop
turns setup from programming this
content will be specific to the a twenty
eight and eight forty control going
through operation of the system jogging
seven pools and offsets will look at
some the content as we go through as
well as part programming
my name is Chris Pollak for those of you
that may not be familiar with me
I am the dealer support specialist for
the East Coast for Siemens and I will be
I will be presenting today's content for
you my information is up there on the
screen certainly if you don't have a
chance to write it down now and you
don't have it again these recordings
will be posted for further viewings you
can come back to get my information if
you'd like to reach out to me with
further questions
so this these live seminars they're new
for us we've been trying to get them out
once a month over the last a few months
we've had a few that are ready 30 gone
through and we have a bunch more coming
up in the future so today we're
certainly doing the shop turn set up a
programming content next month's going
to be a little tight with the test shows
so I probably won't have an opportunity
to post the next one till October
but the next one will be shot milk so
it'll be very similar layout content but
it'd be specific to shop milk for the a
28 May for tea after that we do a
commonality between shop milk program
guide and tamp and ISO mode so that will
kind of show you how all the different
modes of the control kind of work
together and move between them depending
on depending on how you create your
programs whether they're coming out of
camp system writing a keyboard at the
control or use example so that'll be
another one and then we'll have many
many more coming up in the future the
content will be specific to you know any
of the three primary controls in our in
our market 842 a 28 and the 808 control
as well I did say earlier but all of
these recordings are posted on our CNC
free website as well so you can access
that if you would like to so today again
we're specifically looking at the 8:28
and the 840 platforms overview today
we're going to take a look at CNC shop
turn and apply it to a two axis turning
machine so we'll go in we'll talk about
set up a little bit talk about how to
set some basic part zeros move the
Machine around we made some tools
we're certainly going to go in and
create a core program and even go as far
as run it in the machine so you should
get a pretty good understanding from
start to finish of what it would take to
set up a job create a basic program and
even run it in this system
this is the example we're going to use
when we get to our programming example
so a simple turning example we're going
to face off our part we're going to
create a contour as you see we'll put a
nice little relief we're going to come
down in and machine a thread on the part
we'll machine a one inch eight thread on
this part once we've done that we're
going to drill a hole through the center
of the part so you get a chance to see
how the drilling cycles work and then
we're going to Park the part off using
recordable cycle so when we're all said
and done we should have any complete
part I will keep bouncing back to a PDF
that I have just to refer you back to
the dimensional data as we start to put
different features in this this webinar
is probably going to take anywhere from
an hour to an hour and a half I didn't
want to cut it short so we'll get right
into it right now so the first section
we're going to look at it's going to be
job mode so in jog mode we're first
going to take a look at the jog screen
or the manual screen so this would be my
main screen where I can start to move
the Machine around we can do tool
changes we can set some basic offsets so
we'll come through we'll talk about the
TSM screen then we're going to go and
look at how to set a tool zero and a
part zero through the measure workpiece
or the measure tool function we'll take
a look at the offset table a little bit
right create a tool and we could even
maybe create a tool as we're writing the
program I do have electric tools pre
created for us as well so with that
being said what we're going to do is
we're going to switch over to our sinew
Train software and sinew train is
basically a machine tool emulator so it
is the identical software you would see
running physically on your control it
gives you all the same functionality so
I can move the machines around I can set
0 you can go into auto mode on one part
program so it gives us a very good
representation of what the machine tool
would do in an offline piece of software
and this software is absolutely
available in the marketplace so if you'd
like to purchase it it is very available
for
so the first screen or first function we
were going to talk about is the TSM
field so first before we going further
where am I added and control what am I
looking at well right now we're in the
jog screen I know I'm in the jog screen
because if I look at the upper left hand
corner I see them in my image my machine
mode and my jog screen light is up
typically this is usually the first
screen you see where you power pollution
pool possibly if your machine requires
referencing you may see the reference
point screen first to initiate a cycle
start or go through whatever the
manufacturer-specific
homing process would be and then if
that's the case the next screen you will
see be jog generally it's one of those
first screens you'll see you in the
power position so the jog screen was
created to allow you to start moving
around the machine setting all sense now
we created the functionality of this
screen to be very aware of keeping
things simple for operators not
regarding them with a lot of heavy
cumbersome commands and instructions so
you'll notice as we go through it
there's a very a lot of visually
graphical screens that kind guide you
through the process of setup and moving
machine around we keep you from having
to go to maybe like MBI screens and put
in a lot of g-chord import functionality
just to keep things simple so with that
being said the first screen we're going
to take a look at is our TSM screen and
that is the button in the lower left
hand corner of my display and what TSM
allows me to do is TSM allows me to do
tool changes spindle commands other M
codes so if I want to fire my coolant or
something a little more blindness or
whatever I happen to have attached it to
the machine I can load different work
offset I can even change my unit of
measure so all this stuff if we can
build one or two it'll give you a pretty
good understanding of at least the start
of the mechanism so the way tools work
in the Siemens world is you're going to
potentially have tools sitting in a
physical location this would be a
position or it's physically loaded in
the machine or they can be in what we
call an unload
so we allow you to build or move tools
from inside of the machine tool through
outside locations just by being in a
loaded State meaning they have a
location to the left physically in the
machine or we call an unloaded state
meaning that they still exist but they
don't exist in the machine some builders
force you to make tools that are
automatically in an unloaded state and
angle of reloading process other
builders do not really clean it up to
the Builder having wants to set up the
machine so in this case let's say I'm
going to build a tool in an unloaded
state I could select new tool and now I
see a full tool library of different
tools we support we're initially just
looking at what we call our favorites
screen so this is some very common tools
you might want to use then you can go
into more detail tool show you all
different kinds of cutters right angle
heads and all sorts of different die
mold and mills and ball and mills drills
social servant drills and taps we
support all kinds of been turning tools
we do special probes and star probes and
stops the whole arge list of cool
libraries that are here for you normally
most of stuff you're going to use can be
found under the favorite screen so let's
say for argument's sake we were going to
come in and create a standard standard
turning tool so maybe it's going to be a
roughing tool so I'm going to leave the
roughing tool highlighted and then I
have these orientations now may be hard
to see on your end but if you look close
you'll notice that the first one has a
little orange tinge to it
orange competin relation to the other
tools well I can move that orange
highlight around to each of the tools
using my arrow keys so this is how I
define the orientation of the tool how
it sits in the physical machine this
machine is set up as it was a slam bed
so this is a rear turret so this first
tool would represent an OD tool if this
machine was a front turret machine then
you would see everything would get
looked backwards our icons our placement
will always represent or match the way
the machine is built so the first
position
represents ability tool but you might
see the icon would look like this third
one over here so what you'll do is
you'll kind of scroll through and you
have a whole bunch of I'm going to do
neutral tools I'm getting all my
orientations for my neutral tools we
have in this case eight different
orientations I can pick from so this one
I'm going to pick my first orientation
and I'm going to say okay now I happen
to have the naming automatically turned
on so it gave me a rough name and this
is probably one of the first things that
guys notice that's a major difference
from us to a lot of our competitors is
the fact that tools do not have to be
numbers and although they can be there's
nothing wrong with being a number but
you can call it anything you want I like
it because I can build in kind of user
comments or notes right into the name of
the tool so let's say for argument's
sake I wanted to build a 35 degree tool
I could tell it it's a mic capsule on a
V nmg and maybe it was a 3/32 insert I
see and radius and I happen to know that
that is an OD tool so this would be a
normal way for me to put in some
different information I have right in
the name of tool shipbreaker you get
pretty elaborately we support quite a
few quite a few characters within a
given name you type in the name whatever
you want letters numbers we support
anything you want there even you see
forward slashes and so on line we can do
special characters you hit enter and
then it moves the highlight over to the
X line enter on the control would also
be the yellow input button right here
the length for X and the length Z will
get filled out when you do the set
length functionality so your main
numbers in there unless you happen to
know your presetting tools or have known
data you can type them in directly the
next thing would be my radius I have a
number two rad so that would be no 31
radius so I'm going to type it by
primary cutting direction now the system
figured that out based on the
orientation I chose but if I wanted to
flip things around
would change my primary cutting
direction certainly the two primaries
for this tool would either be down or to
the left you'll notice if I put the
wrong cutting direction we put a little
indicator here on the insert to say and
things aren't quite driving so in this
case I'm telling it
so the recording show just initiated
thanks again everybody for attending
this is easy C and C with shop turns
setup from programming this content will
be specific to the eight twenty eight
and eight forty control going through
operation of the system jogging some
confusion offsets we'll look at some the
content as we go through as well as part
programming
my name is Chris Pollak for those of you
that may not be familiar with me
I am the dealer support specialist for
the East Coast for Siemens and I will be
I will be presenting today's content for
you my information is up there on the
screen certainly if you don't have a
chance to write it down now and you
don't have it again these recordings
will be posted for further viewings you
can come back to my information if you'd
like to reach out to me with further
questions
so this these live seminars they're new
for us we've been trying to get them out
once a month over the last a few months
we've had a few that are ready 30 gone
through and we have a bunch more coming
up in the future so today we're
certainly doing the shop turn set up a
programming content next one's going to
be a little tight with the dyeing test
shows so I probably won't have an
opportunity to post the next one till
October but the next one will be shot
milk so it'll be very similar layout
content but it'd be specific to shop
milk for the a 28 May for tea after that
we do a commonality between shop milk
program guide EDM and ISO mode so that
will kind of show you how all the
different modes of the control kind of
work together and move between them
depending on depending on how you create
your programs whether they're coming out
of camp system writing into you go to
control or use example so that'll be
another one and then we'll have many
many more coming up in the future the
content will be specific to you know any
of the three primary controls in our
market 842 8:28 and the 808 control as
well I did say earlier but all of these
recordings are posted on our CNC free
web site as well so you can access that
if you would like to so today again
we're specifically looking at the 8:28
and the 840 platforms overview today
we're going to take a look at CNC shop
turn and apply it to a two axis turning
machine so we'll go in we'll talk about
set up a little bit talk about how to
set some basic part zeros moving machine
around great some tools we're certainly
going to go in and create a core program
and even go as far as run it in the
machine
so you should get a pretty good
understanding from start to finish of
what it would take to set up a job
create a basic program and even run it
in this system
this is the example we're going to use
when we get to our programming example
so a simple turning example we're going
to face off our part we're going to
create a contour as you see we'll put a
nice little relief we're going to come
down in and machine a thread on the part
we'll machine a one inch eight thread on
this part once we've done that we're
going to drill a hole through the center
of the part so you get a chance to see
how the drilling cycles work and then
we're going to Park the part off using
recordable cycle so when we're all said
and done we should have any complete
part I will keep bouncing back to a PDF
that I have just to refer you back to
the dimensional data as we start to put
different features in this this webinar
is probably going to take anywhere from
an hour to an hour and a half I didn't
want to cut it short so we'll get right
into it right now so the first section
we're going to look at it's going to be
job mode so in jog mode we're first
going to take a look at the jog screen
or the manual screen so this would be my
main screen where I can start to move
the Machine around we can do tool
changes we can set some basic offsets so
we'll come through we'll talk about the
TSM screen then we're going to go and
look at how to set a tool zero and a
part zero through the measure workpiece
or the measure tool function we'll take
a look at the offset table a little bit
right create a tool and we could even
maybe create a tool as we're writing the
program I do have electric tools pre
created for us as well so with that
being said what we're going to do is
we're going to switch over to our sinew
Train software and sinew train is
basically a machine tool emulator so it
is the identical software you would see
running physically on your control it
gives you all the same functionality so
I can move the machines around a lot of
your standard manual functions from
there let's say I wanted to jog the
machine around so I can jog utilizing my
axes right here so I pick a given axis I
can select the plus or minus key I can
start to move the machine around
maybe I want to move Z so I select thee
you'll notice this has a y-axis plus
about other axes certainly this machine
could support many axes this one's just
commissioned for a couple this was built
to support C axis capability in light
tooling we won't be going through that
today but we could in the future
absolutely
so with that being said maybe I want to
come in and set a tool offset very
common occurrence that you'll find
yourself doing when setting up a job for
a lathe well certainly the first step
would be load the actual tool that I
want to set you know potentially turn my
spindle on to some direction because I'm
going to come in people like Pat or
whatnot and then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use this measure tool
function so measure tool allows us to
come in and set our tool offsets so once
I select the measure tool button is
selected by going blue I just clicked on
that button I can now pick in the upper
vertical soft keys are operating in
corner the manual or the automatic
buttons so manual would be I'm going to
physically come in and manually set this
tool probably take a light cut on a
piece of material automatic would be if
I had a preset or examination so we're
going to go through just manually
setting the tool today I select the
manual function you'll see that the tool
is already pre-selected it knows what's
in the third or what's loaded so it
automatically defines that I would then
probably you know jog machine or annular
machine to some location come in take a
light cut we would go down measure up
our part maybe mic up that diameter and
then I would tell the system in the x0
field what is the diameter I'm
physically sitting at so you usually
take a cot mover straight back and Z
leaving the X is still aligned with that
edge shut the spindle off measure it
maybe we found that we rode two and a
half inches I simply type the diametric
value 2.5 this is well automatically cut
that in half or and then I merely type
it in and then press the SEC length
function so before I hit it I want you
to take a look at
work field the work field is displaying
our absolute positions relative to some
offsets from zero so you see how it's
sitting at twenty three point six eight
right now we hit set length and all of a
sudden it applies to two point five in
our control whenever you set any offsets
we will immediately load those offsets
same scenario if I was to adjust the
offset maybe by flying or where so we
were running this tool we wanted to
maybe go to the offset table go to my
where field and tell it that I'm maybe I
was a little big so I want to reduce the
offset by five now well if I come back
out you notice I didn't physically do
anything with the tool or move the
machine but immediately it's reflecting
that also so whenever you're setting any
offsets you always want to verify as
long as that's the tool that's called up
or the work points hold up that the
display physically change if it didn't
you need to stop and kind of go back and
figure out maybe what you did wrong as
to why that tool didn't properly update
or that it also didn't update so in this
case Z if it came over to the light cut
in the face of the part I could tell it
zero I can tell it some small positive
negative distance depending on where I'm
setting it but I did the same process I
give it a value
I hit set length my offsets change now
you're going to do a lot with measure
tool cuz you have a lot of tools setup
typically in the lathe so here I can
stay within this screen so let's say I
was to move back move out a little bit
now I want to change to some other tool
well if you have arrow back up to the T
field in the measure tool field we can
initiate tool changes just like the TSN
screen you just saw so here I hit select
tool we can maybe arrow down to our
finish cutter say okay
tool name is now loaded we'll talk about
tool names in a little bit impatient
tools but the tool is physically loaded
now I just have to execute it by hitting
a cycle start you see now loads the new
tools my offsets change because I don't
have an offset yet for this now I would
repeat the same process
I would potentially jog down over some
location maybe will Z and then give the
machine till it whatever axis I'm
setting it will retain the value so if
I'm just going to touch a lot on to a
predefined axis value I don't have to
keep typing them each time then I just
say set length for each of them and I've
just established offsets no just follow
that pulses
the graphics will update depending on
the tool that you selected so you know
if you go to drill and then mills you'll
see it will update to reflect that and
try to give you a little better process
of what we'd be expecting you would do
to set this tool generally you knows a
lot of different ways to set up blades
generally you know a lot of guys like to
set up all their tool offsets either to
a fixed datum or to maybe just the part
and then they'll adjust all the tools by
applying some value in a record so in
our machine you can do that by simply
going in I'm just going to put that
turning till we had in before back in
we're simply going to my measure
workpiece field measure workpiece allows
me to move over to some location so
maybe I was to move to some position now
this is let's say where I wanted to set
a work coordinate value so what the work
pointer value would do a little move all
this will the same amount so if I had
pre-established maybe all of my tools to
the base of my chocolate set and I want
it to now move over just one given tool
touch the front of my new part and then
have all the tools set there this would
be a good example of where I would use I
measure workpiece field I would move the
machine back touch a physical part
select whichever work coordinate I want
to work I want to use tell it what I
want this value to be so maybe I'm
hitting a one to three block use a paper
shim stop I could tell it maybe
a small value from their hit set work
coordinate you see mail my display
changes now that value didn't change for
the tool offset it actually applied to
the work coordinate so we'll go in to
look at the offset table normal second
and you'll see where some of these
values grow as well other common things
you can do within the job screen will be
maybe position the Machine around so
here I can tell to you know pika some
location maybe I wanted to go to an X of
2 inches cycle start machine would run
and do that as commanded feed move and
do rapid moves here so you can just kind
of move the Machine around its work
envelope this way we give you a basic
stock removal screen this is a simple
can cycle that allows you to do basic
simple stock removal so if you wanted to
turn some soft jaws like today and you
know maybe I'm going to work on an ID
set of soft wheels I wouldn't have to
write a whole program I could fill out
this one little event once I fill it out
and I have good numbers here then you
will get the accept key and once it's
happy this becomes a little program so
like that will go and hit cycle start
and this program should run I didn't
give it any valid numbers but it's a
this quick snip away from able to do
some basic events and depending on the
machine tool you've purchased and how
the Builder is configured it we may
bring up a lot of these different hand
cycles up on the screen a lot of our
teach lays engine lights that have the
ability of running on a manual and CNC
like a hybrid machine they'll give you a
whole bunch of different camp cycles up
in this mode and they I will work kind
of the same way now what we want to look
at here as well we were kind of moving
the Machine around and jogging around
setting proloff sex I do want to show
you the offset screen briefly so in the
offset screen I'm going to get there by
hitting my hard offset button I will see
our tool table and the tool table is a
physical tool list the tool list is
going to contain the tool the offsets
and some of the geometry that makes up
the given tool tool where is just how I
can adjust small incremental values
where I also have my tool life
management here magazine is more
reserved for machines with like milling
machines with random tool changes and
parent cells and whatnot but you do have
the ability of that functionality here
as well as a more complex machine then
offsets is where all of my work
coordinate or work well filter several
so if I come in and I look at my g54 I
can see where that number got inserted
when I did that or coordinate offset set
so just like when I set my clever pool
now these values are a distance from
some machine location potentially to
wherever I was setting the tool if I was
basically everything off of this the
gauge tool overworked coordinate then
these could potentially be just small
incremental values from some data to
that tip so with that being said let's
say I wanted to create a tool from
scratch why don't we build one at least
so you can see the mechanism certainly
we don't have enough time to build all
the tools for the whole part program but
I can set 0 you can go into auto mode or
on park program so it gives us a very
good representation of what the machine
tool would do in an offline piece of
software and this software is absolutely
available in the marketplace so if you
like to purchase it it is very available
for you so the first screen or first
function we were going to talk about is
the TSM field so first before we going
further where am I added in control what
am I looking at well right now we're in
the jog screen I know I'm in the jog
screen because if I look at the upper
left hand corner I see them in my
mission my machine mode and my jog
screen light is up typically this is
usually the first screen you see
whenever you power pollution for
possibly if your machine requires
referencing you may see the reference
point screen first you initiate a cycle
start or go through whatever the
manufacturer-specific homing process
would be and then if that's the case the
next screen you will see be jog
generally it's one of those first
screens you OCU in your PowerPoint
machine so the jog screen was created to
allow you to start moving around
machine setting offsets now we created
the functionality of this screen to be
very aware of keeping things simple for
operators not bombarding them with a lot
of heavy cumbersome commands and
instructions so you'll notice as we go
through it there's a very a lot of
visually graphical screens that can
guide you through the process of setup
and moving machine around we keep you
from having to go to maybe like MDI
screens and put in a lot of g-chord
important ality just to keep things
simple so with that being said the first
screen we're going to take a look at is
our TSM screen and that is the button in
the lower left-hand corner of my display
and what TSM allows me to do is TSM
allows me to do tool changes spindle
commands other end codes so if I want to
fire it my coolant or something we'll
move on to mist or whatever I happen to
have attached it to the machine
I can load different work off so I can
even change my unit of measure so all
this stuff is very typical functionality
that you would always do through an MDI
screen and a control but by creating
this simple little interface screen it
keeps the users from having to know and
learn all these heavy-handed commands so
if I want to do something as simple as
just physically change my tool now if I
look at the tsf window the tsf window is
just a quick representation what's
active at this point in the control so
it knows that I have some punch cutter
physically loaded maybe some fees or
some spindle speed states so if I simply
come down then I can move my highlight
around with my blue arrow to my tool
field I can now hit the Select tool key
in the upper right hand corner and get
access to my tool table so my tool table
is showing me all the different tools
that are physically loaded in the
machine horrible so let's say we wanted
to spin tutor position number one and
bit to our CNN G 432 or our 80 degree OD
roughing tool I can simply highlight
that tool by moving up with the blue
arrow keys
select okay machine fills out the name
of my tool and now it's just waiting for
simple cycle start by pressing cycle
start
initiate a tool change automatically
important so the machine now would do
anything to build or prompted or wanted
it to do for change it has to go to a
read track location to go to that
retrack location if they're just
allowing the server to spin at that
point it would do that but you'll notice
in the TFS screen I now see my new tool
loaded in my turn so it's fun to that
position would have loaded any offsets
that may be set for that tool and I can
now continue moving on that tool I'll
use this for maybe turning my spindle on
so let's say for argument's sake I want
to start up my main spindle at 500 rpm
and I want to give it a direction I'm
going to use my select key to define
some kind of a direction so I want to
move clockwise and now I'm going to
simply hit the cycle start key and
you'll see I spin a little turn on my
feedback will even show me that the
symbol is now spinning everything is
running so these are the typical steps I
would use to spin the turret to some
location pirate my spindle and get ready
for maybe setting a tool setting an
offset as well if I wanted to load up a
work coordinate I could come in select a
specific work coordinate that I want to
use that I'm going to activate from
setting zeros cycle start and that would
initiate loading of that work or
anything within the GSM screen will
require a physical cycle start to then
activate I can also use this to maybe
turn my spindle back off if I wanted to
by using the X with the circle through
it cycle starting that command spindle
shuffle so you'll use the TSM screen to
do